anh
alo alo cho các bạn với mình đi
Alo ạ à
Xin chào tất cả bạn ạ
à à
à Hôm nay chắc là ăn sớm đâu một tí
tranh thủ Tâm sự tí nhỉ à
à mình mình bỏ về bên skul rồi đưa mình
sẽ còn nữa 31 này
web từ từ sẽ đổi thành là có hỏi đi câu
hỏi nó sẽ hợp lý hơn câu hỏi này cũng
thấy hay ho này và tâm sự có hỏi
lại khá như thế này à
ừ ừ
anh đã bị kích khỏi this code à Xin chào
mày lại bấm Mày cứ đừng lên lại xong rồi
bị chặn rồi đúng không ạ
a a
trong bữa hôm nay có thể mình cũng sẽ
hướng dẫn các bạn là dùng ra Suite để mà
làm xóa cái đoạn bình luận như hôm trước
mình có nói là
tool của Facebook bây giờ chạy qua
grab.api của nó bị chặn khá nhiều nên là
bây giờ mình sẽ
mình sẽ có thể dùng ra Swift - người
thừa Mình đã học để mà già lập lại những
thao tác của mình giả sử là bấm là một
cái gì đó hãy thích Họ nói Chúng nó lại
phải là bấm là đồng cái gì đó chẳng nào
thì mình sẽ xóa bình luận là
Ừ từ một bài đăng nào đó một cách tự
động thì sẽ như thế nào rút gọn à
ở tại thì À hôm nay mình xin chia sẻ tâm
sự tranh thủ trước à về 3 khái niệm này
bác Khái niệm và
ở đầu tiên thì
ở
với mình có điện thì
kiểu dạng là mình phải đặt ra những cái
kiểu gọi nghe các tiêu chuẩn này những
cái kiểu định hướng rõ ràng
Ừ thì khi có cái khái niệm về Ví dụ ở
đối với mình thế nào thành công nhờ ạ
Đây là tâm sự mà nó bảo thế nên là mình
cũng không hẳn đã quy chụp mình quan
điểm của mình nó luôn đúng hay là kiểu
các bạn phải phải theo quan điểm này
Đừng đừng có nghĩa là ông thầy này dậy
mình lập trình nên em phải nghe mọi thứ
thì ông thầy này nói không phải như thế
bạn mình sẽ chia sẻ góc nhìn của mình
xong rồi Các bạn thấy ổn khi
đó luôn là bài toán là nó cũng na ná
giống như là các bạn xem livestream của
bất kỳ người nào đó thôi Đó là bản thân
là người ta chia sẻ góc nhìn nhưng mà
chưa chắc là người ta đã hoàn toàn đúng
ý cho con mình nghe mình cả cái có thể
đã nếu mà không hay thì có thể nó coi
như một thứ giải trí thôi cũng được đâu
ạ
thì với mình quan điểm thành công ấy bởi
vì có nhiều bạn hôm trước cũng bảo là
kiểu học lập trình thì bây giờ mời cậu
là
là kiểu dạng là vua mệnh nghề không bao
giờ thành công này nhà người khác thì
Kiều sẽ khó thành công chả thế
Ờ hoặc là anh
em chỉ lấy vợ khi mà em thành công rồi
Khi mà em thành đạt rồi
Thật chứ Ổn định thành công đó nhiều
người sẽ là ổn định sự nghiệp
đối mình có điểm cái thành công nghệ thì
nó ra nào giống như người bạn đấy cũng
nói đó làm chuyển khi mình đạt được một
cái cụt cột mốc nào đó mà mình cảm thấy
là cột mốc để nó khóa quan trọng thì nó
sẽ thành công
ở
nhưng mà với mình thì thành công nó đôi
khi là từ những cái bước rất là bé thì
phải đặt mục tiêu thắng trước đã để mình
đạt được nó chị đã mình đừng đặt mục
tiêu xa quá thành ra lại mình vẫn phải
có những mục tiêu gần và xa nhé
ông phải luôn luôn có mục đích đến để mà
ông biết đường mà đi không ạ Chứ không
thể làm luôn dậm chân tại chỗ hay là đi
quanh quẩn được ông chuyện đi Kênh còn
rồi Tự nghiêm đúng phát ông đến được cái
đường thành công nếu không ạ Ừ đấy ông
og được tiêu vẫn phải đặt một cái đích
đến đã đích đến đây chưa biết được rồi
lúc đấy nó có chuẩn được thành công hay
không nhưng mà ông ông cứ Ít ra cũng
phải đặt một cái đưa để ông đi đã đón
khi mà đang đi ở chùm móng cảm thấy có
gì đó không ổn thì không thể rẽ nghìn
nào đấy nhớ ra ông còn có một cái gì đó
khiến chị ạ Chứ ông không phải lanh
quanh dậm chân tại chỗ này hay à quanh
quẩn lý quay còn lại em chỗ
thì thành công đối với mình ấy thì nó nó
là
sự thành công lớn nhất thì chắc là sẽ ra
có một gia đình có gia đình được hạnh
phúc các Hương sơ để đỡ mình những thành
công không phải thành công dụng mua nhà
hả Ông ngoại mua xe không cần phải kiểu
kiếm được tỉ đô hay cái gì đó đối mình
thành công đó là như thế mà tư cái thằng
không đấy đối mình là rất là to lớn theo
kiểu từ đấy mình sẽ phải Ok để mà gia
đình hạnh phúc thì chả ra kèo phải kiếm
được một người kiểu người vợ hiểu mình
hợp mình những loại
thì và đương nhân không thể một một cái
lều tranh hai trái tim vàng có thể sống
mãi được họ mình sẽ biết được là mình sẽ
cố gắng những cái gì để mà kiểu
giữ được người đấy và để đạt được cười
đấy vì thôi k còn mình cũng hơi tham lam
một tí đó là kiểu gì cũng muốn là kiểu
vợ mình cũng phải
xinh xắn giỏi giang chứ không phải là
kiểu cứ ai yêu mình là được
chị
đã hết mình đặt hiện cái chữ tiêu chí
dần dần dần Sau đó mình sẽ biết được
mình cần phải làm những cái gì đó sẽ
mình đặt ra mục đích
Ừ
cái mục đích xa nhất sau đó dần dần dần
các bạn phải luôn hỏi câu hỏi là tại sao
và làm thế nào đấy tại Khánh Như thế
theo tôi cũng dần dần dần mình định
hướng được chú ạ là mình cần phải làm
những cái gì
nếu mà đương nhiên thì À
cái việc đặt ra Thế bây giờ tôi khẳng
định luôn là bây giờ gần ngựa ông nặng
đã tạo được những cái khuôn mốc lá rồi
có thể là mình không Đang làm hoặc là
thậm chí đang hơi lười là thì cái việc
đấy
chúng ta cần phải có động lực để mà ngày
nào mình cũng sẽ dành là giống như kiểu
ông đặt ra mục tiêu đấu 6 múi nếu mà ông
Mỗi lần ông đi tập Joong Bị Lạc Thành ra
có lời thật hôm nữa đi du ngoạn không
phải có một lực lượng gì đó hàng ngày
nữa thì thì cái động lực Hàng ngày ông
phải kiếm đâu mà các động lực hàng ngày
thì ông
có thể đi được đến cái đích kia chứ tôi
Tôi không biết về ông như thế nào nhưng
tôi không phải là một con người Kiểu
tôi thì tôi từng đăng ký đi tập gym võ
của mỗi bơi mày là tôi đi thường xuyên
được chứ mấy cái kia tôi toàn đi một hai
buổi sao nhỉ
Ừ
thế nào tôi không để khẳng định tôi là
một con vịt kiên trì khẳng định mình
được đấy nhưng mà tôi luôn kiếm cái gì
đó động lực để mà đi cùng để mà có thể
làm được gì đó lâu dài em ạ
đây mấy ông kiểu gì liệu phải kiếm được
cái điều động lực đem thành công các cứ
đúng không kiếm được thì mail không Đừng
đừng có nói đừng có nói là kiểu nói
xuống đi rồi em sẽ sử dụng ý chí của em
không chuyển được đâu đúng ạ một người
nhắc nhở mình hàng ngày hai cái gì dưới
đó động lực hàng ngày với em được vào
mấy ông phải nhìn được mỗi ngày mà mình
gần đến được đích đến của mình thì mình
càng có thêm động lực cái gì đó loạn
em lấy lý do Phòng Jim nó có cái gương
đấy ông này nào soi bản thân Tiến triển
như thế nào đúng không em có thêm động
lực thôi
à à
Ừ đấy thì à còn 4 phút mình xin phép
chia sẻ về quan điểm giàu
Hồi trước cái quan niệm dầu của mình
Thực ra cũng như bao người là giàu là có
xe cộ thận chứa biệt thư xanh xanh tí
nữa giúp nhưng ở bên Tây sẽ có hồ bơi
xong rồi
trực thăng nó thứ
đấy Kiểu sao
Chứ mà khi mà hồi mình vào đã cắt thì
mình quay đi hồi Mình công nhận nó khác
đi Tí đó là họ khó cái câu hay ghét đó
là cả bạn sẽ không được phải được cho là
giàu khi mà bạn luôn phải đi lạc càng
ngày mà không đi là thì bạn sẽ ra bạn sẽ
phải I
các bạn bạn sẽ bị hết tiền rất nhanh
kiểu cứ thế mà không tiêu pha được thoải
mái như bình thường nữa ta sẽ phải tiết
kiệm không tìm một năm nữa là bạn sẽ trở
thành chả có gì trong tay cả
Ừ nếu mà quan điểm như thế thì kể cả ông
Lương 1 tỷ 2 100 triệu em vừa triệu thì
chả hạn như nhau đó là vẫn nghèo
cho tôi 1 tỉ đó vẫn chưa là giàu Bởi vì
ông không đi làm nữa thì học đạo là
lương nổi loạn thì thì ông
cũng sẽ thành nghèo thôi
Ừ thì thế này là bên đa cấp ở đây nó có
con đỉa cả ông phải có nguồn thu nhập
thụ động thì và ông không cần đi làm nữa
ông vẫn chưa Pha lại máy tiền ông vẫn
tăng lên thì đấy mà giàu
Ông nói ông tiêu pha vẫn như bình thửa
Anh bình thường không không hô không
phải là không phải là kiểu ông Tư pha
kiểu phá mà vẫn vẫn tiền vẫn tăng nhé
Cái đấy rồi quá mức rồi
Vì
sao mà ông tiêu pha giữa bình thường à
Ừ nhưng mà vẫn thoải mái
mà vẫn cháy hưởng đúng không cần phải
cải đạo phải đi làm
đấy con điểm giàu
thì anh em mình vẫn đang đi làm thuê
không biết ở đây có ông chủ nào không
hay là ở nhà nhà mấy ông đang chỗ
có hẳn ra tay gì đó để lại cho mấy ông
ấy Ông chẳng cần phải làm gì cũng không
biết nhưng mà những anh em đây cho chủ
yếu vẫn đang điểm thuê thì chắc chả ra
lương mấy ông thế nào thì không đưa cho
giàu đâu Đúng đoạn thì không phải biết
vì sao chắc là gọi dùng từ đầu tư cũng
đúng nhận được tư vào những cái gì đó ê
ê đi e nó có thêm nguồn thu có thứ thì
mới cho dầu
bọn chúng ta đều nghèo như nhau thôi
lương chúng ta hãy khác nhau nhưng mà
chúng ta đấy đấy giống chuyện đường dịch
này tôi có bạn kiểu nó có cái cửa hàng
bán ở phố Cổ đấy Thư nó kiểu nhà có ba
cái nhà liền nghe về rất giàu sau đó thì
kiểu biên dịch gửi cái hai năm liền
không bán được hàng ông ấy phải bán Mất
100 rồi đấy còn gọi là giàu ấy không
đúng không Dịch mà còn cao hơn nữa gia
sư đấy ngon nếu mà mới không kiếm thêm
nguồn thu khác thì bây giờ cuối cùng thì
ông ấy không thể không kiếm thêm tiền
ông ấy tiền
tiêu rồi lại càng giờ khó tiêu như một
cái bình thường đúng ngoãn Thế bây giờ
cuối cùng ai đang giàu này
Ừ
đúng ạ Nói chung là về các bạn học bên
kinh tế thì thì các bạn sẽ biết về khái
niệm này hơn mình mình không Họ đến kinh
tế mình không biết được nhưng chỉ đại
khái với Minh quan điểm nóng như thế vì
kinh tế các bạn sẽ Biên dõi cái ra chị
các thứ tài sản
Ừ nó Khái niệm dùng từ là tài sản và
tiêu sản lại cái gì đó nữa cơ à
khi mới bắt đầu buổi học rồi chào buổi
hôm sau mình sẽ nói qua cái cái chích
nhé
Ừ
cái mấy cái tôi đang tâm sự cũng là cách
để mấy ông tán gái rồi nếu không thì mua
chém gió cái đấy Mấy bạn con gái cũng
thích nghe
thấy ra tù đấy nếu mà ông hướng đến mấy
bạn gái cho cậu là học thức và kiểu
[âm nhạc]
và kiều dạng là thần tượng mấy anh kiểu
trí thức không phải là tri thức Nhưng
mấy anh kiểu lớn tuổi hơn mình kiểu
thành đạt Giỏi ra các thứ thì nếu nói có
tí triết lý là ấy rồi cậu thể hiện mình
là con người có quan điểm chính kiến và
trí thì mấy ông đã đổ 8 đồ mà em ấy rồi
gửi mấy em đấy Nhìn mấy cái ông mà thấy
ông bạn đồng lứa xung quanh toàn mấy
thằng trẻ trâu kiểu thằng ở Xuân Này chị
biết game sẽ hiểu gì đó nóng ạ à
ở Đại Đế các Thạch đáy của tôi
nhưng mà tôi nói nói chuyện của con gái
đôi khi vẫn ngã nhiều phải là bọn này nó
vẫn cảm thấy mình có cái gì đó để mang
kiểu nên đang lắng nghe nên nó vẫn nghe
không ạ ạ ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ thôi bây giờ bắt đầu buổi học đã giống
vào rồi thì hôm nay như mình có đây cập
hôm nay mình sẽ dạy
giới thiệu qua việc p
đầu tiên p thì nó là ngôn ngữ
vẫn là ngôn ngữ lập trình nào giống kiểu
ra Speed
nhưng mà nó khác là một điểm là nó nó là
hôm trước mình có Đề cập về vụ và fany
mà bắt em nó xử lý krait size và
server-side các bạn nhớ bạn
hoặc là mình sai ạ Tại vì cho các bạn
xem ở
à à
ờ ờ
[âm nhạc]
để mình phải có một cái ảnh
từ trước
ở
tại Thái như thế này à
mà
tại sao lại có xé đấy nhỉ
khi bật Minh Trí Đợi mình tí nhé
khi con cảnh bọn gửi hình dung hơn
thì tại sao tự nhiên của cs ở đây
à à
ở đây này có vẻ ổn Đấy
hình ảnh hồi bé em đi
Ở đây Ờ đầu tiên thì đây là trình duyệt
các bạn đúng không ạ đây xuống dưới các
bạn khi các bạn Nhập một cái đường Linh
gì đó giả sử facebook.com để hạn nó gọn
các bạn thấy nó trả về cho các bạn cái
Trang giao diện của Facebook có thứ
đúng ạ Các bạn thực sự là không hiểu
được là nó làm thế nào ở ra được cái
trang web đấy nhưng các bạn không cần
Nếu bạn là khách hàng người dùng người
bạn các bạn không cần quan tâm gì đấy
Không phải chị biết dùng thôi không ạ
còn chẳng màng quan tâm mà nó sử dụng
ngôn ngữ gì hay cái gì đó lúc ạ
và mịn và trình dược nào nó hỗ trợ mình
cái đấy Đúng đoạn trình duyệt thực cả AE
thấp nhất cho đến trình duyệt Chrome bây
giờ đều chạy được mấy trang web đấy loạn
Ừ thì chúng ta ở đây mà điều đó là gì đó
là
nó xử lý là xử lý ở phía server server
là sẽ xử lý nó sẽ yêu cầu bằng nó sẽ xử
lý bằng một ngôn ngữ lập trình nào đó
trong trường hợp này giống như mình
chuẩn bị dạy sẽ bằng pp loại sau đó thì
nó sẽ xử lý xong nó xảy ra bản chất là
như mình đề cập đó là trang web Hiển thị
như này
ở bất kì gà trong cái kiểu như thế này
hãy xem cái kiểu như thế này cái này cái
ảnh muốn nói thì nó đều là hplc s +
Speed được Nó không có TP nào lấy cả nó
không có tí java hay suy gì ở đây cả ạ ạ
em không bấm vào được đổi trả chết
ừ ừ
ở đây ảnh đỡ hơn tí thôi thì thì cái cái
Các bạn nhìn tương đối thôi cái ảnh em
thừa nó mờ sẵn rồi
cài cái trang web đấy nó sẽ được lót lên
hiển thị lên các bạn đúng ạ thông qua
việc là server nó sẽ làm dùng vào bất kỳ
ngôn ngữ lập trình gì
I see p2 ra ba gì đó nó sẽ tạo ra hát
Tiệm lờ gần như ở chủ yếu để tạo ra thêm
Ờ thôi còn sẽ là Swift thì thì thường là
viết bằng luôn CS và Speed chứ không
dùng pp để tạo ra hai cái đấy thường là
sẽ không làm thế sau đó đi nó sẽ trả về
cái tài liệu hồn htl ở CS ra Suite đấy
trả về cho máy người dùng đồng loạn máy
người dùng sẽ hiển thị ra cái đấy Đều ạ
ạ
tin tức là sao nghĩa là
mình Bây giờ mình đã học được hát tlz ra
suýt rồi mình sẽ PR sẽ học tiếp t để mà
làm từ pate nó sẽ sinh ra được HTML để
trả về cho người dùng để hiển thị ra
tại sao lại có vụ đấy Ở đây Tại sao mình
không làm hết mà hpl sẽ ra Speed mà tại
sao tự nhiên mình phải có phải dùng ngôn
ngữ lập trình đó là bởi vì kiểu bây giờ
mình sẽ thử đề cập cái á cái này
em
giả sử bây giờ các bạn thấy đây là Trăng
trang web mình vẫn thương ai demo trang
này nhưng mình thấy anh nói vì trang tin
tức ở một cái trang rất là cơ bản nó rất
là cơ bản Nó gần như nó chỉ chỉ dẫn giải
hiển thị kiến thức tôi nó không có gì xử
lý cao siêu cả đúng ạ thì các bạn thấy ở
đây có hàng nghìn thậm chí A bây giờ
chắc phải lên triệu bài đăng bài báo rồi
Mấy bạn thì người lập trình viên của
mình nó sẽ không thể ngồi cốt 1 triệu
file HTML cứ mỗi lần nó đăng một bài báo
thì nó không phải ngồi Cốt lại phải file
file HTML đúng ạ hết nó sẽ làm gì Bây
giờ mình sẽ thử cho các bạn xem hai cái
bài báo này ngọn Các bạn thấy hay bài
báo kiểu nhà mình thử đặt bàn cân lên
các bạn so sánh nhá
à à
ở
đài kiểu ngày tháng Nguyễn Trãi mà tao
mới phải này đây
em kéo xuống đây
Các bạn thấy là nó cũng rất giống nhau
về cơ bản nó rất giống nhau đây
anh đều là có tiêu đề ở trên cùng cái
này có thể thể H1 này đúng loạn trên
cùng này là thêm menu đúng ạ dưới này nó
sẽ ở bên trái nó sẽ có mấy cái mục gì đó
Mày ngu thì gì đó nữa đấy Sau đó thì
sưởi này là bài đang nội dung bài đang
này đúng là có thêm cái ảnh cảnh ạ Đấy
nội dung bài đăng này nhắn nội dung bài
đăng này dai bé đang này thứ có thêm một
cái nữa chắc là nó chèn thêm mỗi bài này
nó muốn có thêm này thôi đúng ạ
ạ
sau đó thì nó sẽ có thêm tim liên quan
xong rồi bình luận này sau đó thì những
cái này ở dưới nữa đúng ạ thì cái cái
việc mà
gì để mà sinh ra được những cái bài báo
như này nếu mà các bạn nghĩ rằng là nó
tạo bởi hát em là lâu thuần thôi không
Chẳng ai làm thế Cả nó sẽ là loại gì và
sẽ tạo trước một cái khung HTML ở đây
Các bạn thấy nó sẽ có 10 không Nó là còn
may nói ở trên này sau đó thì có cái chỗ
này mà để tiêu đề này có chỗ để mà để mà
nội dung này có chỗ để mà tin liên quan
này bởi Tiên liên quan của hai thằng này
có thể chắc chắn khác nhau rồi đấy ạ Chỗ
này bình luận là chỗ để những cái bài
liên quan nữa này Chỗ này quảng cáo Vân
Vân Vân đúng ạ Có chỗ rồi Nó gần như tạo
những cái đít có sẵn như thế sau đó thì
sao sau đó thì toàn bộ những cái bài báo
này nó sẽ lưu lại ở một chỗ mà mình từng
học rồi đó lưu lại ở trên tầm bậy nó
equal các bạn thường gặp rồi bọn ta sẽ
lưu lại trên tàu sân bay mình sẽ dạy
Oppa nhưng mà ở khóa sau nhé á
Ừ thế thì
nó sẽ lưu lại hết lalabay những cái nội
dung của bài 5 bao gồm Giả sử tiêu đê đã
Hà Nội dung bài đang các bạn Đấy sau đó
thì cái ngôn ngữ p nó sẽ lấy từ từ
database ra nội dung đấy sau đó đổ vào
trong trong cái file HTML để này để mà
in ra cái nội dung đấy trong cái file
HTML đúng ạ sợ sau đó thì khi mà có HTML
đấy rồi sẽ thì mình biết sẵn rồi để đúng
loại sau đó mình trả về cho máy người
dùng máy người dùng mình bị ra thôi Nó
ngọn Đấy đấy là khái niệm cơ bản nhất
của của việc mà kiểu xử lý các bạn thấy
nó sẽ xử lý và server sau đó là như thế
nghĩa là bao gồm việc là khi mọi người
dùng gọi lên một cái bài báo kiểu như
này thì nó sẽ kiểu hiểu à Mày muốn đọc
bài báo này đúng ạ và sẽ lấy thông tin
được bạn bài báo từ trong tao bay ra
xong rồi nói in vào trong cái tài liệu
HTML
để mà nó trả về cho máy người dùng đó
bọn đấy thì mình có thể dùng bất cứ ngữ
lập trình gì nhưng trong trường hợp này
mình sẽ dạy các bạn phải fb thì Đầu Tiên
Bây giờ các bạn sẽ phải hiểu thì các bạn
thấy hiểu bản chất là hồi trước mình hay
làm đó là mình sẽ dùng HTML và chạy luôn
lên chính cái trình duyệt của mình bởi
vì em lúc đấy Máy của mình sẽ hiểu là
máy mình sẽ là Klein xa luôn nghĩa là
máy mình là mày khách Hà luôn không ạ
Mình sẽ code rồi chạy luôn trình máy
mình có bây giờ các bạn thấy à mình sẽ
phải cốc cả server size nữa Ừ
[âm nhạc]
thì mình kiếm con đâu Con server bây giờ
thứ hai con server đấy nó bản chất nó
cũng là
nó cũng là một con máy tính
và có máy tính này thức a nó cũng chính
có thể chính Máy mình cũng được nhưng
với điều kiện nó cần phải chạy cái con
máy con mèo phải cấu hình của một con
server để chạy thì thường là các bạn sẽ
phải cài phần mềm để mà chạy gái cái cái
con server lấy thì mình thì mình đang
cài nó ra làm đây là và Gòn các bạn có
thể cài shopee cũng được một trong hai
cái này nhá mình người ta dùng là gọn
với mình sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn thử Dragon
đi về mình ngại cài lại shopee lắm Hồi
đầu Mình công nhận mình học thì mình
càng shopee nhưng mà nhưng mà bây giờ
thì mình cảm thấy à tất cả các rừng già
có thứ là còn Nhanh tiện hơn để hỗ trợ
thêm nhiều cái thứ hơn em mình sẽ hướng
dẫn các bạn là Gold nó tương đương với
các bạn sẽ thấy là cài hai cái xong mỗi
nó sẽ có rất nhiều cải tưởng tương đương
hồi nó không có gì à hiệu phức tạp khó
hiểu đâu các bạn gần như bấm đánh knak
rồi mà quan tâm gì Đúng loại Ok là sử
các bạn hack nick xong hết thì nó sẽ ra
được cái này à
khi xảy ra được cái thư mục tại thư mục
kiểu như thế này đối với Lego nó như thế
đồng loại
à à
cho
thịt bò
sau đó đi khi các bạn cài này xong thì
thì làm như nào đúng ạ thì đầu tiên là
các bạn sẽ phải mở nó lên đã thì đây cái
mở lên của nó sẽ trông như thế này à
tác giả sử mình tắt hết đi nhá thì à mở
lên lúc đó sẽ trong như này và các bạn
để mà khởi động giống như mình vừa nãy
có đề cập đó là khởi động để mà chạy
được cái server đúng không ạ thì có bạn
sẽ ở đây này so các bạn là bỏ qua mày
cái này các bạn cho tự hiểu sao cái này
bạn ấn vào bên này cho mình mắc định các
bạn sẽ cần mở hai cái này để mà nó là
cái con để mà server Ảo thì các bạn chạy
đấy không quan tâm được cộng lắm đâu
không còn nói chuyện cổng lắm đâu
và mai kia mai kia hình như mình có đề
cập giống như hồi các bạn học với Word
ấy ý Ừ thì các bạn cũng phải mở cái FTP
server Dạo này em bảo là máy Ware để mà
chạy quen thôi Có sẽ mở hai cái này của
mình thì mình đang dùng cái nick này
cũng được mi nick này đọc tương đương
với ô che nó không khác gì nhau đó thì
các bạn mở hai cái này cho mình ạ hoặc
mở như nick với máy queo Tùy các bạn
đúng ạ Còn nó tương đương nhé ok rồi
ạ
sau đó thì các bạn Chính là step nó lên
thôi Nó sẽ trong nhà sau đó nữa thì
Uh cho nó nữa thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ
không tốt được dạng giống như là kiểu
hồi hồi trước mình thấy cốt nữa bản full
thì sẽ sẵn nó sẽ luôn đầy đủ các thứ hơn
bạn có thể bố nhưng mà các bạn Nếu mà
mày các bạn cần nhẹ và các bạn muốn trải
nghiệm nhanh như các bạn tải bản
Portable nó vẫn chạy được vẫn đây vẫn đủ
các bạn dùng rồi
ờ ờ ờ
thì các bạn sẽ không Cốt theo kiểu dạng
như hồi trước các bạn hãy cốt nữa là các
bạn cốt ở bất kỳ ở đâu cũng được rồi các
bạn chỉ cần chuột phải vào như này chọn
chạy là chạy được hợp cái thời đấy Thời
Học ht1 lồ nhé Còn bây giờ mình học HPT
thì mình sẽ phải cốt hết vào nằm trong
để thư mục gọi là thư mục chứa cốt của
cái phần mềm các bạn phần mềm Lego thì
các bạn sẽ phải lưu vào trong thư mục
www như này các bạn tạm một cái thua mục
gì đó đồ ạ tạo một thư mục gì đó trong
này giờ và lưu hết cốt trong đấy Tìm
chạy
cho con con nếu mà với shopee thì các
bạn sẽ có trong thư mục HP dog như thế
này có bạn sẽ phải tạo một thư mục trong
HT đó rồi có bạn mới chạy được cốt để
trong đấy đây giờ sự trong trường mầm
này mình sẽ mình đã tạo sẵn một cái chua
mục là uschool nằm trong
www như này rồi
Bên mình cứ tặng xóa Hà Nội để bệnh được
Kệ
thì mình sẽ mở một thư mục à
Vì vậy mình xem
Ừ thôi tôi xóa hết đoạn này đi Tôi mệt
mỏi quá
Lê Thị xóa hết đề gì nhỉ con như chúng
ta chả có gì cả Ok Thế bây giờ đầu tiên
mà mình sẽ tạo một cái file pp đầu tiên
của mình nó bọn nó phải Halloween em ạ
Mình sẽ lưu file này phải
đặt tên là gì nhỉ Mình sẽ đặt để mô đ.tp
đi
Em hãy nên nhớ một điều file pp Nó không
chỉ chứa mỗi TP mà phải TP nó sẽ có thể
chứa cả HTML
CS và ra Swift và đương nhiên có cả TP
nữa đâu ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ cái
ạ bây bây giờ Bây giờ mình sẽ có một cái
dọn Tháp một vợ to em ạ thì sẽ là Hello
Hello trả lại như này các bạn nếu mà bấm
chuột phải vào các bạn sẽ không còn khái
niệm mà openid prô nữa vì nó sẽ không hỗ
trợ các bạn chạy từ đấy với sắp laita cả
như thế còn dùng IDE thì cho nó vẫn hỗ
trợ các bạn chạy trực tiếp
à
[âm nhạc]
Thế bây giờ làm thế nào để chạy được
code bây giờ nóng loạn bé ơi
ạ
bây bây giờ cách để mà chạy thì các bạn
sẽ mở trình duyệt lên như thế này à
thì các bạn mở cho các bạn có thể đối
với à đối với thằng Dragon này để để
mình thử Lâu lắm rồi không sợ
gì chú school lại như này được
Ừ cũng được đấy các bạn ạ
sau khi mà cày là ngon hoặc cả soompi
Xong ấy
thì các bạn sẽ có khái niệm là bây giờ
khi mà gõ local hot như thế này
anh lạc local hot
sau đó gạch chéo tên Thu lục của của cốt
của các bạn vừa rồi mình đặt tên thư mục
cốt là di tru school nổi loạn thì thế
nên là khi mình gõ local host rồi Chu
school nó sẽ ra được toàn bộ cây chuối
mục file thì các bạn nha và các bạn muốn
chạy file nào giờ sửa file demo chậm P
là các bạn bấm vào được cái nó xảy ra
được gọn
ai
đấy Cái này cũng tương đối sẽ hiểu mà
đúng ạ chẳng qua nó hơi phức tạp một tí
giai đoạn đầu vì các bạn mất công cài
đặt này cũng như là không tiện nó như
hội họp HTML Các bạn bấm chuột phải và
chạy luôn không bao giờ các bạn phải gõ
2 địa chỉ như thế này là local host cho
tên thư mục thường là mình hồi Mình mới
học đấy thì cách để mình nhớ là mình sẽ
dây kéo này xuống đây luôn này để lần
sau mình chị bấm vào nó sau đấy Kiểu thế
hoặc các bạn thấy sửa nó lại thành kiểu
như thế này
Ừ cái kèo nhà sửa lại tên nó nữa chẳng
hạn dụng là cốt chanh ăn sẽ
có tên nó hiểu ngay thôi Mỗi lần bấm vào
nó sẽ ra cây thư mục để các bạn chọn lên
file loại cho tiện của đấy Mình học nó
như thế
ừ ừ
à à
ở đây đại khái là như thế này các bạn sẽ
thấy file pp của mình chạy được
a HTML đúng không ạ thấy là chạy TP thì
chạy như thế nào đúng ạ Nó sẽ có thể
riêng của thể pp để chạy
Ừ thì nó sẽ là như này thay vì mình làm
như thế này mình sẽ là anh tệ thẻ PR
thế cho Hello
xin chào các bạn đi
cái này
thì các bạn sẽ thấy là nó sẽ sẽ là có
thể in a được chữ có dấu hay các nêu
Minh thường thôi nó phải nằm trong chuỗi
Bởi vì các bạn học lập trình rồi mà
không ạ thì chỗ thì bắt buộc phải có dấu
nháy nháy hoặc cả dầu ngày đôi đúng ạ
Mà chị Astro này nó là gì đó là hàm của
cái t để mà im ra đó giống hàm prince ở
trong là nhiều ngôn ngữ lập trình khác
thì trong này nó lại ích chúng Sao đọc
cái này cô đấy mày cho mày thấy sinh
viên mình gọi ấy chó nữa Nói chung đại
khái như thế thì mày in ra một cái gì đó
thậm chí là cái này có thể dùng đổi in
được cả HTML nhưng thường là tôi khuya
mà Mấy ông không Bơ dùng pp in HTML vào
nhé xe tải kiểu như này không thể đi
thẳng in htl nhà cũng được vẫn được
đấy các bạn thấy thời gian nó chẳng thay
đổi thì cả bọn
[âm nhạc]
Ok
nếu mà nội dung của buổi hôm nay chị
giới thiệu thì có khi là thế này các bạn
tắt máy kết thúc kết thúc buổi học được
rồi Nhớ lên nhiên là hôm nay không chỉ
đơn giản mỗi thế đúng ạ
Anh à
Hôm nay mình mình sẽ dạy các bạn về
ở những những cái kiểu những cái đầu
tiên là với ngôn ngữ lập trình nạn thế
nhưng mình đã từng nói là tiên là biến
nó sẽ à khác gì so ngôn ngữ lập trình
khác còn ít keo rồi thở ra các bạn bất
kỳ ngôn ngữ lập trình làm đều giống nhau
trừ bên battue để Ngạn bitol thì nó sẽ
không dùng mà dấu chấm phẩy long run sợ
tát rồi còn trong này nó sẽ dùng la
Speed là kiểu phòng đặt pho còn ít theo
các thử giống nhau hết
nó Tức là xa và sửa đây là
đầu tiên về khái niệm biến trước đi
khái niệm biến ở trong g-suite thì các
bạn Hiếu bọn nó led sau đó tên của cái
biến rồi bằng cái gì đó đúng không ạ
Con còn trong trong đây thì nó sẽ dùng
đôla đồng bọn nó sẽ Đôla
xe tải nếu mà ông thầy bói nó bảo với
ông là tương lai của gắn liền với đôla
thì có thể liên quan đến với P đấy
ví dụ Giả sử là mình sẽ cho biến biến
thì đương nhiên là trong này nó đặt tên
Hình như là không có gạch dưới là không
gạch dưới được cả đâu ạ Ừ đúng rồi này
thấy đi nó sẽ là đương nhiên là không có
dấu không có giấu nữa nhé Cho sẽ vẫn là
phân biệt khoa thường này
đó sẽ là chữ này
số lần đầu như là không được đâu chữ
xong rồi số như này mới được thì cha nó
giống ra Speed thôi nó chữ này
số này
Mày cứ ấy đấy không có dấu cách không có
không có kí tự đặc biệt khác không có
bệnh nhanh không có có dấu đã
Thì
[âm nhạc]
đại khái ở Giả sử mình lập biến ở Hà Nội
như thế này và đương nhiên là nó giống
ra quyết và 1 điểm
ở ở là nó không cần phải khai báo kiểu
dữ liệu của nó nên lúc đầu mình cho biển
a = 5 cho mình cho biến a bằng chuỗi như
này bằng B giảm ạ vẫn vẫn được chả sao
cả đây là mình thử in ra biến thì bạn sẽ
thấy à đó vẫn in ra rất bình thường
không báo lỗi gì cả
khi bé là ngôn ngữ không chặt chẽ
dùng từ không chặt chẽ là bởi vì à Không
kéo Dạ lại thì lúc đầu nó thể một kiểu
về sau nó không biết Nó là kiểu gì chúng
nó ạ ạ
à à
Ừ đấy thì bây giờ ra xưởng mình ít theo
cho nó thì rất đơn giản thôi là sự mình
ít ở đây đôla nhỏ hơn mười là bạn thì
mình sẽ thấy cho đi làm cái là biến A
nhỏ hơn mưa ấy lại khá như thế em ở đây
là
bé Na
a
lớn hơn hoặc bằng
10 Chẳng lẽ ạ
vì thế các bạn thấy ít béo nó rất giống
kiểu ra Switch điểm là kiểu nó sẽ ít này
thôi trong này kiểm tra điều kiện xong
rồi có mặc ngọn ngồi bên trong này thôi
chấm phẩy có thứ như thế này không khác
gì do suốt cả à
Ừ
ok bị mình nghĩ là giới thiệu qua như
thế tâm đối rồi nghỉ bây giờ mình sẽ đi
đến những cái phức tạp không tí đi
Làm sao để mình nghĩ xem buổi đầu mình
sẽ dậy những cái gì theo buổi đầu của
mình hồi hồi mình đi dạy ở trường mình
nhé Bởi vì trường mình họp ra Speed nó
bị cách sau P khá nhiều nên là hồi hộp
mình dậy cái tên mình lại phải dạy lại
vòng lặp lại cho mình mất tận cũng phải
mất 10 buổi một sợi cái t cơ Còn bây giờ
dạy kiểu ngay hôm trước mình vừa họp ra
Speed hôm nay học xong TP mình nghĩ là
mình không được dạy các bạn về ít theo
vòng lặp nữa
à à
Ừ đúng rồi Thế chỗ ở đây thôi cái cho nó
là hàm các bạn chuẩn là các bạn phải cho
nó cho mặt tròn như này
nó nói chuẩn mà rõ là biết kiểu nhà á
môi mình sẽ dạy thêm một cái nữa cũng có
về Eco đây giả sử là ờ các bạn muốn in
cảm biến biến này và trong này luôn hiểu
rõ sự là Be số đổi này số đi à
Ừ nếu mà các bạn ghi kiểu nhảy thử ta ở
trong nó ở trong có kiểu kiểu bị kiểu
hót cốt tất cả kiểu đi thẳng vào trong
cốt cái số ngày không tốt
mình muốn cho động nó theo cái biến A là
Nhạn thì mình sẽ có khái niệm và kiểu đồ
bé Ngọc đổi cái nháy đơn này Thành ngày
két kiểu như thế này sửa đổi cái này
thành đô la như thế này thì nó sẽ hiểu
là các bạn in được biến ở trong chuỗi
Còn nếu mà nháy đơn như thế này có bạn
sẽ không Nguyên đột biến ở trong chuỗi
các bạn thấy được kết quả là vẫn như thế
nhưng trong trường hợp lần này nó in
biến ở trong chuỗi à
phiên bản tiếp theo đỏ nữa
Ý là mình có thể là nếu hoặc Giả sử
Trong trường hợp là bạn là không không
không muốn kiểu đi thẳng ở trong chuỗi ở
nhà mình nối chuỗi thì ra
nối nối lên một cái đoạn chuỗi nữa Các
bạn nhớ về bên gia Swift thì nó sẽ nối
chuỗi là sự là xin chào các bạn nhỏ mình
thể nối thêm kìa tên Long nha Để em ạ
sau đó thì nó sẽ trở tạo thành Xin chào
Long lúc ạ Xin chào Long kiểu nhà từ
trước khi ở méo cách là nhà thì nó mới
cách ngày không ạ Đấy còn trong pp thì
cái nối chuỗi nó không phải bằng dấu
cộng như thế này các bạn nhớ là thằng
g-speed Chính vì để nó dấu cộng như này
thành ra có cái vụ và kiểu 3 cộng với
kiểu
chuỗi 3 kiểu nhảy hàng baba ạ Các bạn
nếu vụ này không ạ
thì kiểu như này nó trải nghiệm Không hề
tốt gọn
cách cộng trừ nhân chia trong Pes nó sẽ
hiểu là chỉ làm được với số thôi chú
phải khác và gia Speed Speed + được cả
cái chỗ ấy con để nối chuỗi trong TP thì
nó sẽ phải bởi dấu chấm như thế này rồi
chấm để nối chuỗi
anh lắm nhưng trong trường hợp này mình
sẽ nối chuỗi mình sẽ kiểu rồi chuỗi thêm
một cái gì đó
hiểu chưa hihi đồ ngốc chào ạ
Đấy kiểu nhà
nó sẽ nối chuỗi bởi dấu chấm để ạ
các bạn đương nhiên là các bạn thường là
mình thấy đôi khi mà để cho nó dễ nhìn
tí thì chuỗi có chuỗi nhiều nhiều Anh
chuyên nghiệp mà tôi biết đấy thì không
không dùng biến ở trong chỗ này mà lại
thường ấy nối biến ra ngoài
nghĩa là cái nháy này thường anh ấy đơn
sau đó thì nối vào bạn sẽ là kiểu nhà à
Xin chào tạm xa lạ này đi cho đỡ day
tôi đổ cái này lại còn nháy đơn này nếu
mà ngày đơn như này như các bạn đang
thấy thì nó sẽ là
không hiểu đây là biến
à mà sẽ hiểu đây là kéo
nó sẽ hiểu đề đô la luôn Nhưng bây giờ
tôi sẽ đóng cái nháy này sớm này tôi đây
nối tại bến A và như thế này đó Nó kiểu
như
cái tôi thấy mình thì anh chuyên nghiệp
thì mai làm trở lại để nhìn cho có rõ ra
cái biến thay vì để nó trong Trỗi
đó thì các bạn thấy ý thực ra Kết quả nó
như thế thôi vẫn chưa Trông có phải dài
dòng hơn nhưng mà lập trình viên đôi khi
làm nó có lý do nó nhìn cái này thử ta
nhìn cái này các bạn sẽ thấy nó có tí
tưởng minh hơn à
Ừ ok Ờ vừa rồi giới thiệu bây giờ cũng
đang 8 rưỡi cũng hợp lý lời tiếng rồi
Nhiều tiếng còn lại mình sẽ làm gì
tôi sẽ Các bạn nhớ bài tập hôm trước của
trên
tế cái bùm ạ ạ
Ồ
thật chứ tôi còn chưa trả lời câu hỏi
vậy
ừ ừ
anh ta cái này thì tôi trả lời rồi đấy
a Cho tôi xin phép trả lời câu hỏi trước
lại nhé à
ờ ờ
Ừ cái này chắc là tôi sẽ
em trả lời riêng bạn đấy đi bạn bạn đã
hỏi thôi Con này thôi thôi
thôi trả lời riêng đi thậm chí là câu
này thì ra ông là thích thử thách ông
vào tí tội xảy ra bài tập võ cô Sao lại
đi Xem hoạt họ có thể hoặc là làm cái
này bằng quý khách được để kiểm tra việc
là
cái đoạn đẳng sau đó phải khớp nối đoạn
đường trước như thế là
tiếng nghèo có một bạn hỏi lại cái vụ
hôm trước về cái vụ làm à
tuôn Facebook hiện có bạn hỏi là mấy cái
ông bán like bán tăng like tăng comment
Thuận sẽ tăng người theo dõi thì làm như
thế nào thì hôm trước tôi có Đề cập về
vụ to Kem các bạn nhỏ bạn có kem ảnh
chất nó sẽ là tương đương quyền của một
nick mới loại tương đường quyền của một
nick cũ nghĩa là chỉ là
mọi thao tác của một nick nào đó sẽ
thông qua các em được đề thi thi sẽ có 2
cách để mà cả bạn và tăng like hay trong
Follow hai tăng bình luận của một cái
bài đăng nào đó
kể chuyện ăn hôi đó là các bạn có nhiều
Token của nhiều nick để các bạn spam à
trong kia thì cách để có tóc em à nhiều
nick thì nó sẽ là một là ông lừa người
ta
Ông còn thi ở Thường hội trước có trò là
tạo ra một cái trang mấy cái trang đăng
nhập thực ra là mày cái xác lập Giả Mạo
kiểu đường link nó sẽ là kiểu facebook
like như thế này đã chấm net thằng ạ Đấy
xong mấy ông cũng bị lừa với cái bấm vào
cái đường link này Sao có cái giao diện
đăng nhập so với ông đăng nhập vào như
thật
ạ sau đó thì à
để nhận skin Liên Minh Huyền Thoại cái
kiểu kéo lên đấy thì thì mày Ông đăng
nhập vào sau đó như béo bị lộ to Ken
đúng rồi nó hình thức thí sinh thí sinh
không không Hình như Office này bí xanh
tại SEA bass fishing nó không phải đi
thế đâu fpc mình nhớ là web VSIP II
à à
lời bài hát thí sinh nó phải như này thí
sinh kia câu cá thí sinh này mới đúng
này đây là câu người này
à Cái hình thức thí sinh này nó sẽ là
kiểu câu câu Mấy cái trong ghép nha cậu
lừa đảo giả mạo để mấy ông kiểu điền các
thông tin cá nhân của mấy ông ấy vào thì
bây giờ là điền thông tin tài khoản
Facebook của mấy ông của Tại sao tôi dạy
học 120 ông tôi không dạy học nhảy sang
với những cái khác lên 150 ông vậy Alo
Ừ đấy Thì đại khái là à
Ê mấy ông bị lừa sẽ sẽ cậu thường là mấy
ông kia Không không lưu lại tài khoản
của mấy ông cũng chẳng để làm gì đâu mà
ông ấy không Nếu cái lừa thận bí nhìn
tài khoản mày không phải không có thời
gian rảnh Mấy ông ngồi vào từng tài
khoản để làm gì đó đâu
mà Mấy ông chủ yếu là lấy cái tô cân của
mấy ông này đi spa để mà bà nói bạn
không phải bàn nick của mấy ông đâu mà
chỉ đơn giản là
thường hay à
Bán nick mấy ông làm gì mấy ông có thể
mấy ông và thấy có hình thức gì ở lạ lạ
là mấy ông cậu lại đăng xuất Lại mất
nick của nó nó ạ lại đổi lại đổi mật
khẩu lại mất tích Đây là nó thường hay
chị
thường hay chị dùng Token của ông này đi
spam like hay ạ Hay là spama
flow Ai đó Đúng rồi spam tương tác kiểu
như kìa thì hợp lý hơn
thế nữa một
cách tốt nhất của mấy ông đó là mấy ông
Thịnh Nếu mà thỉnh thoảng đổi mật khẩu
Tôi thấy gần đây có một cái cho tôi
không
có cho như thằng mô nó làm gì đấy
số tự nhiên có bắt thủy thủy hoảng bắt
người dùng ở đổi mật khẩu đến nỗi vậy là
còn chẳng nhớ mật khẩu của mình nó là
một khẩu gì đã học Facebook nó còn chọn
ra dị nữa nó nó còn lưu lại mật khẩu cũ
của mấy ông mếu không được phép đổi
trùng anh ra là đổi hình như là Lần Hơn
là nói mười mấy ông mới được đổi lại mật
khẩu cũng
thành nha là cứ mỗi lần tôi phải đổ mật
khẩu Này rằng là tôi cứ cho thêm một số
nữa với số của tôi lên đến tầm 4 năm mấy
rồi
Vì
thế nên à à
a a a
Ừ
cái cái trò đổi mật khẩu là tôi không
khiêm tục đổi mật khẩu lắm trong
Facebook của cho là xem lịch sử lịch sử
tương tác a
em có nhật ký hoạt động ấy mấy ông thể
vào đấy thường xuyên xem Để xem mình có
nhật ký hoạt động gì ở bất thường hay
không
Anh nhớ Hình như là nếu mà vào Facebook
nhé tôi tôi nhớ có phím tắt nó là A1 thì
phải ạ
Em có nhớ à Thằng Facebook phải có mấy
cái phím tắt này là nhảy sao trang chủ A
nhảy sang cái gì đó
nghe nó nhảy bằng ra Swift rồi nên mình
phải đợi Lót cái này xong đã rồi an gì
gì đó
Ờ Ờ để tôi An hỏi chấm xem nó ra
em shit à
Hai giao diện mới Facebook nó không hỗ
trợ vụ này nhá
hình như không được rồi hội chợ có vẻ
không được không được thôi không xa các
bạn ấn vào bên là đây là từ VTV lót rồi
Các bạn xem này sẽ ra có nghề ông mà
không biết vụ này theo kiểu là mấy ông
xem lại được cả những video các bạn mấy
lần tôi mới làm khó chịu là vụ được gặp
à
Mấy lần khó chịu vụ là đang xem thử
video quên chưa kịp thích đó hè chưa kịp
bình luận đấy nói cho kiểu tự nhiên
Facebook lại cái mất xử với video đang
xem rồi mày ông hoàn toàn thì vào đây
xem lại được Mày
xem video đã xem à Cái gì đó lịch sử tìm
kiếm này đã bình luận ở đâu rồi Đã kết
bạn tôi đôi khi còn xem cả cái vụ Em à
mình đã từng kết bạn với ai xem lại được
cả lịch sử mà ví dụ là ngày này mấy năm
trước mình đã kết bạn với ai đúng ạ
Có đấy nhé
a hoàn toàn xe máy kỷ niệm cũ để tôi
thấy các bạn nhiều người lắm đấy Kiểu
thế vào đây mới ông xem được mấy ông đã
theo dõi ai đã thích những bài đăng nào
để mà Mấy ông kiểm tra xem mà có dấu
hiệu gì đáng ngờ ấy không tự nhiên lại
đi thích mày cái lạ lạ đúng không ạ thì
mày sẽ biết được là mấy lọn tóc em nụ to
kem thì ạ tưởng mày không phải đổi mật
khẩu rồi chọn đăng xuất ra khỏi mọi
thiết bị khác thậm chí là vô hiệu hóa
tài khoản rồi đăng nhập lại cũng được
Để để chắc cũng là chắc chắn gió tô kem
cũ nó sẽ bị vụ vô hiệu hóa không còn
hiệu lực nữa
đấy đại khái như thế à
[âm nhạc]
Ừ ừ ông kia vào muộn bây giờ Hỏi bây giờ
học p à mới học xong sử hơn thôi à
À hôm trước cái bạn Phương Linh kia lừa
tôi cái vụ ra Speed thì thực ra là
thường là nhiều người nhiều ông thầy sẽ
rất ngại vụ là kiểu bị sinh viên lừa hay
bị sinh viên kiểu hỏi hỏi những cái hàm
có thấy không biết
Ừ nếu mà tôi không quan tâm gì đấy bởi
vì à Tôi tôi thì ạ Lúc mấy mấy người còn
thấy tôi thử cái hạt đấy cho rồi tôi
biết được có thể hàm ấy dán 01 tại như
là tôi không chắc chắn được điều gì mình
vẫn là thử đã mới có rất nhiều hàng thật
ra mình không hề biết và thực ra là nó
muốn là nó cũng sẽ ít ít khi được dùng
nên là vấn đề xóm giờ biết thế là tôi sẽ
không khẳng định gì cả tôi cứ thử thôi
Làm - viên mình mình không lại thử mà cứ
điều đấy chả mất gì cả nên méo nuôi khi
mà tôi thấy nhiều nhiều ông đến khi hỏi
ca nhạc
hỏi mấy câu mà tôi nghĩ là mấy ông ấy
thử có thể thử luôn Nhưng mày với ông
mấy ông có thể bị lừa thì có cả mấy ông
sợ máy nó bị sao không biết được
mấy ông lên thử đã
nếu như là hỏi cũng được nhưng mà ý tôi
là vì sau nếu ông đi thực tập mà ông hỏi
mấy câu đấy thì không ai trả lời Mấy ông
đâu không ạ mấy ông sẽ họ phải hỏi những
cái mà cậu mình thử chán chê rồi không
được hai mình không biết cách để làm cái
gì đó thì mình bị hỏi thì nó sẽ hợp lý
hơn
à Hôm trước có đề cập cả vụ dùng quay
selector 2 Prison Break to để mà lấy lấy
á thay vì còn nhớ cái vụ là Dortmund
chấm gattermann body cái gì đó để mà lấy
cụ thể một cái gì đó đóng lại thì cái vụ
nó có vụ khái niệm là quay selector như
này và nó sẽ dùng theo kiểu cách gọi
giống như ở của cs gặp như kiểu đô la là
thăm như này sẽ là ai đi
cho ví dụ ID kết quả là ạ thì sẽ lấy
được của cái đít Deep qua ID là kết quả
đâu ạ Chưa cách này cũng được nếu mà
hình như mình để cập ở thuật cao là
đây đây là trẻ thêm những cái hàm nữa để
mà các bạn biết qua ra tiếp thôi về sau
cũng chưa chắc ở áp dụng nhiều vì về sau
chuẩn là các bạn sẽ
anh cũng không dùng cái đau Comment này
mấy nữa bởi vì công ty nào bây giờ vì
sao cũng phải dùng những cái Facebook ra
Spears hay gà thư viện gì đó không phải
viết một câu quá dài dòng như thế này để
mà lấy ra một cái gì đó nghe mình không
cần lại dậy sau mà cái vụ đấy
biết qua thôi
ờ ờ
em
có bạn hỏi nữa về cái vụ
à
Hôm trước về vụ Mình bảo là đăng nghiệp
bằng Facebook hay ở tài khoản Facebook
với tài khoản Google thì mấy cái thằng
bên thứ ba để có biết được mật khẩu các
bạn không thì có trả lời vẫn là không
chắc chắn nó sẽ không biết mật khẩu của
bạn không như chết luôn
Ừ cái vụ đăng nhập qua tài khoản gì đó
còn nhớ không ạ đây mình cho các bạn xem
nhé à
à à
Ừ tao nữ chuẩn bị làm Tu là số mày
ở
đây mình xin thêm quyền lợi bạn
anh ạ
thì nó sẽ hỏi là có cho phép quyền đấy
không
Hình như cái đi chết rồi
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
Ừ
cái này như của mình ghép nó đang có vấn
đề rồi
ở đại ca thế họ sẽ hỏi các bạn thêm
quyền cái thứ tự thì các bạn khi mà bấm
ok thì nó sẽ luôn xin làm và gửi luôn
cho thằng kia một cái to kem kiểu ngay
để mà lấy được thận những thông tin mày
các bạn cho phép có quyền thôi chứ không
không biết được email không biết được
tên của bạn nếu mà các bạn chưa cấp
quyền đó nó cũng không cũng không biết
được à Nói chung rất nhiều thứ các bạn
cấp quyền đó nó đến đâu thì to scan để
có thể lấy được đến thế chứ không có
chuyện nó nó biết được quá nhiều thông
tin về bạn đưa bạn
nên là tôi mới bảo mày không phải đọc kỹ
xem mà nó sinh những quyền gì tiền hình
gần đây thôi chỉ khó chịu em về mỗi việc
là nó chỉ cần được xin quyền là truy cập
được vào
Ừ tôi đăng nhập tài khoản Google nhé nó
xin quyền thằng ấy sao nó xin quyền là
đọc cả Google Drive chỉ đọc thôi nhé là
cũng ngủ dai firedrive tôi không cho nó
khuyên để luôn thế tôi không đăng nhập
vào nhà tranh ấy nữa nói chuyện thế bởi
vì cậu nó xin mà xin tự nhiên đăng nhập
vào thường là nó chỉ xin lẫn thông tin
cơ bản nó nhận Email đó cả cùng lắm ngày
sinh các thứ thứ đó đã đủ lệnh cảm một
định nghĩa của sự tự nhiên xin quyền
Google Drive Chả hiểu trải nghiệm gì cái
này tôi không không đăng nhập trang này
đỡ luôn tôi mà nói cái trang này nó ra
đây nữa thì phốt qua toán nữa rồi inbox
riêng để biết thế thôi bé đấy Cái cái
trang này ra trang của lập trình viên ở
Long nhá diễn đàn lập trình viên ở lo
nhé mà Trang ấy tôi khẳng định nhà mày
cái ông ấy làm
Ừ nó kiểu không tâm huyết lắm Về cái A
cái cái trải nghiệm người dùng thì phải
ạ
à à
Ừ đúng rồi to kèn này bản chất axít sự
nó là cookie cookie từ cu kia nó sẽ sinh
ra season
à à
ờ ờ
Ok Bây giờ mình đang nói nốt nhỉ Ok Bây
giờ mình sẽ nhảy sang cái Ừ anh sẽ dạy
các bạn dùng ra Swift để mà làm cái xóa
bình luận được ạ
Tại sao bởi vì như mình để cập là đây
mình nhớ mình học là trình rồi mình phải
làm gì đó trong lồng vào lúc ạ thứ hai
là
thực ra là thì mình có thể
dùng pp ngay luôn để mà gọi đến grab.api
để ngồi Xóa bình luận nhưng mà hôm trước
mình cho các bạn xem đấy thì kể Topcare
hiện tại nó đang bị giới hạn quyền để
truy cập đến nữa
group kiểm như thế này nhưng thành ra là
không không không thể gọi được đến bài
đăng này không gọi được đến rút luôn để
để mang ấy thông tin mà đăng lại hay là
lấy được luận này đang này nghe em bây
giờ mình và vẫn cả là
mình cũng đề cập thêm là vụ là nếu mà
dùng các em như thế đâu khi nó bị giới
hạn theo kiểu là nó sẽ luôn nghi ngờ khi
bạn bị xóa mà cái gì nó nhân quá nó sẽ
Kiều bị chặn quyền đoạn thành ra là bây
giờ mình sẽ dạy các bạn sẽ dùng ra Swift
ra Swift và sẽ ổn hơn vì nó sẽ giả lập
hành vi người dùng bởi vì đang chạy lên
trên máy mình nó là máy người dùng là
lúc bạn thì sẽ giả lập hành vi người
dùng là là kiểu bấm thao tác là sự bấm Ở
Đây Rồi Sao bấm và xóa rồi ạ Đúng đó sẽ
hợp lý hơn thì
đầu tiên đây là bài đăng tâm sự của mình
hôm trước mình thường hay làm cái trò là
kiểu bình luận có dấu sao thì sẽ bị xóa
đúng ạ thì tức là sao Ở đây các bạn sẽ
hiểu Nó kiểu cậu chữ là bình luận là một
có chứa ký tự sao thì mình xóa thôi đúng
ạ thì
Ừ thì bây giờ cái việc đầu tiên được cần
làm Đó là mình sẽ à mình sẽ đổi đường
link này đang đi review này hình chữ mờ
như thế này để nhảy sang giao diện của
web à trên điện thoại tại sao bởi vì
giao diện web trên điện thoại nó vẫn rất
là đơn giản đó không phức tạp hướng như
là do diện ở trên máy tính nếu các bạn
để ý kĩ lại ở đây tôi sẽ cho các bạn xem
ừ ừ
thì
các bạn sẽ thấy là giả sử mình xóa một
cái bình luận nào đó như thế này
a dream này con sẽ luôn hỏi lại lý do
các thứ thứ như này nó hiển thị lên mà
cái pass nữa và sẽ khó chịu hơn đấy ạ
hôn Mờ rồi có một mới đi đâu đấy Con
việc ở đây thì các bạn chỉ việc là bấm
và cái ở đâu đấy cái bấm nó ấn vào more
này chọn Delete cái sẽ kiểu nó sẽ hỏi
nhưng mà cái hỏi đây
ở lớp nó vẫn còn hỏi nhớ hồi trước là nó
không hỏi cơ
Anh hỏi để mình xem thử với cái hỏi là
em có xử lý như không nha à
anh còn không nhỉ Cho mình mà nhảy sang
MB thích thật
ở đây đang để mình tắt luôn Tết luôn để
xem mình xử lý được cái vụ đấy Không nó
ạ
Cái cái hỏi vừa rồi nói cái nó là cái
Ừ cái thuộc tỉnh các fan trong gia
Switch Các bạn nhớ hôm trước là mình Họ
cái vụ Plus như thế này nó là Hiển thị
là một cái thông báo Crop như này là
hiển thị ra kiểu lúc mình sẽ nhớ viết
sai đúng chính tả không
Anh ở nhớ như thế này vậy
đã để chị ra cái để cho mình nhập vào
vào cái confirm như này là để mà xác
nhận + Z2 lâu đi vừa rồi
A Gọi thiếu chữ t vậy đúng không
lâu tôi không dùng được không nhớ đâu
đấy thì sẽ có ba cái Hiển thị như thế
này thôi cho anh xem cả ba cái mày ông
dễ hình dung ngay ấy mà
ở đây đổi thẻ thẻ Swift này à
A A
Plus này Hello chào bạn ạ
ở đây thông báo đâu ạ
đây gặp rồi
à à
Ồ thông báo vào đây sẽ là con pháp thông
báo
ở tập tắt từng cái một giá các bạn để
hình dung này
à à
anh alo thông báo đâu ạ
cho tất cả đi này mở này lên này
Ừ cái này sẽ để mặt Điền một cái gì đó
nó loạn đấy rồi tắt đi này mở này lên
này tao sẽ là có xác nhận chứa này Lâu
như thế này đúng loại
Ừ thì bây giờ giả sử tôi sẽ có một cái
đây là một cái Teddy a cho tôi thử xóa
trên cái bình luận của tôi xem tôi có có
dùng ra Swift để mà
ở đây mà xác nhận được được không xác
nhận được cái copper mà rồi không
khi con Phương mà cái chua hiểu thử xem
Ừ nếu nó có khi Địa Công phơi thì à
à à
cơ
quan tương tự luôn
nhà phải xác nhận
em có khỏe không Lâu rồi à
chị xem Switch
control II
Anh tên con phẩm phẩm phúc
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ để mình mình mình đang muốn ở thứ nhất
là có thể không hiển thị công phu với
nữa hay là hay là công phẩm đấy nó sẽ tự
động mình bấm hộ luôn luôn là chết thì
không các bạn hiểu ý mình không
anh còn không thì chắc lại sang mờ thích
thật mà ít thử xem nhé
à à
chị thơ chữ e Thì bạn ạ
Em hỏi nó nhảy Sang trang khác nữa rồi
nó mới nhảy sang tra khác kiểu này thì
cá không tốt bởi vì ra Swift Mình ở sẽ
bị loát lại nên là mình sẽ không phù hợp
vụ đấy Ở đây
à à
ô
ô Nha và Thả tim câu test của tôi vậy
trong xanh
ờ ờ bé mình làm nghỉ à
Ừ mình ở chưa làm vụ xóa cơ mình thường
ai làm Vũ khác cơ à
à À đúng rồi ghi đè lên cái hàm có cơm
nữa để mình thử nhé I confirm à
anh
bằng quy tên Chu Ý bạn thế đúng không lẽ
nó sẽ luôn trả về là Luôn Đúng
Ừ cũng được hết mình thiệu xe à
thì
alo mình ở đâu ở sẽ ở nhà nghỉ à
ừ ừ
thì chả ngon đó mình luôn
khi mình đã luôn cho con phone bằng chua
thế Mình không phải con phẩm đã được
ai ngờ đẩy hơi nhược điểm đấy bây giờ để
tôi mà chạy Xong rồi lỡ xóa mất cái gì
đó Tự nhiên xóa đi rồi nhạy cảm Trang
này sao không hiểu những cảm đâu nhưng
nó không confirm không có xác nhận lại
gì nữa bọn Ok tại Thế à
Bây giờ mình sẽ lấy ra sự mình sẽ phóng
Bình luận đây bình luận
test có dấu sao
Như Lai Trả nợ kém chỉ có nhiều dấu sao
hoặc có một số xa gì gì đó thì mình vẫn
sẽ nhận được cái bình luận đấy loạn
có dấu sao ạ
anh ạ
em thì làm thế nào để lấy là những cái
bình luận như thế này đúng ạ
Trà Vinh
ờ ờ
mà hình như hôm trước mình có đề cập đó
là cách để mình lấy mấy cái kiểu như thế
này bản chất nó cái đít rồi chứa những
cái chữ ở bên trong rồi ạ vì cách này
mình lấy đứng như là bằng gas do mình sẽ
lấy nhanh hơn bằng chèn thêm thu viện
really vào đây mình sẽ nói nhanh lại qua
vụ đấy tính cách thường hay chơi trò
mình sẽ there will be a School như này
chẳng hạn tôi sẽ thương hãy lên lung
linh kiện ngay
à à
Ừ đấy tôi copy đó ngay về sau đó thì tôi
ấn bên A suốt suốt này tôi tạo một cái
clip em gi giờ bạn đồ tôi copy ở đây
giản tôi chỉ lo ăn cái này lên là có
những seri trên trên này đúng là chạy
được rồi Đúng loại
ạ sau đó Thì bây giờ mình làm gì mình sẽ
chỉ cần lấy đít
đít có cái class
ở đây để xem nhé từng cái đít
à à
ở đây Đây là cái thằng bịp
mấy ông thấy đây từng cái đít to lại
thằng Deep Deep Như à
3 cách để đẩy class tháng ngày sẽ thường
hay tôi sẽ thử làm chọn lại tôi chọn cả
cụm như này
có phải phải dùng chọn ở cụ này trông
dùng sẽ đôla
đôla không như thế này nó sẽ ra được đít
là xong rồi ai đi xong rồi class mà nó
còn lại ai Đi rửa rất là nó sẽ Cụ thể
một hàng rồi bây giờ nếu mày thử là
Anh xóa cái ID để đi như này à
ừ ừ
ở những chữ ký chụp cầu của
đó nó ra 31 cái chứng tỏ là có vẻ hợp lý
là đang có 31 Cái hiển thị ra bình luận
nếu mà ông muốn loát hết tất cả bình
luận đã rồi ông ấy chạy Xóa Tôi thường
là hay hay làm như thế
Có 2 cách để mấy hôm Xóa nhá một là mấy
ông cứ Tải hết bình luận ra
chọn sau đó thì lấy tất cả bình luận hợp
lệ
đó thì xóa lần lượt
Đây là một cách học cách thứ 2 đó là cứ
lấy tất cả bình luận hợp lệ sôi loại xóa
lần lượt
ạ sau đó thì mới
lát thêm
sau đó lại quay lại lấy xóa như này thì
cái cái hai cách này mình tôi theo như
tôi thấy thì
à à
ở
với cái bài của tôi đang có thì nó lên
đến 70 700 bình luận việc mình lót hết
tất cả bình luận ra thực ra là nó vẫn
không nhìn nỗi nặng lắm ở bị máy tôi ram
ra mẹ tôi tận 32 cái gì vậy Khá thoải
mái và đây m&m chặn Facebook thì nó vẫn
nhẹ hơn nhẹ hơn so với bình thường
nghe Tôi nghĩ là tôi vẫn bán được hết
tất cả bình luận ra còn tôi khuyên mấy
ông à Mấy ông chơi nên trôi theo cách
kiểu như này thì nó đỡ hơn
A
và thơ ca là nếu mà ông xóa lần lượt
kiểu như thế này
thì tôi nghĩ là Facebook nó dễ chặn lông
hơn với việc Facebook nó sẽ nghi ngờ
việc là ông xóa lần lượt này nó nhanh
quá
nên tôi nghĩ là có khi tôi sẽ áp dụng
theo cách cách như thế này đi là lấy hết
tất cả bình luận hợp lệ xóa lần lượt mà
trước đã sau đó thì mình sẽ lót thêm lót
thêm xong rồi mình lấy bình luận rồi
mình sẽ xóa rồi lại loa thêm các thứ thứ
thì nó sẽ ổn hơn
em làm cả hai cách
hết bình luận rồi Xóa Xong rồi còn bình
luận nào nữa để mà làm cách thứ hai được
gọn ạ
ừ ừ
âm nhạc thực nó nào giống nhau bà đúng ạ
Nó không khác gì nhau đâu ạ
anh nói cho biết đầu tôi lấy hết tại
bình luận rồi nó bạn thì
tôi sẽ xóa là tôi bê bây giờ lấy tất cả
bình luận khác với tao là bình luận hợp
lệ đúng không ạ
thì bây giờ Làm thế nào để xác nhận bình
luận là bình luận hợp lệ thì cái cái này
là lấy ra tay làm bình luận này bình
luận hợp lệ là mình sẽ để duyệt Tân Bình
luận một sau đó lấy cái nội dung của
bình luận là có dấu sao hay không mới
bắt đầu xóa đúng không ạ
ý
[âm nhạc]
thì cái vụ lấy Tân Bình luận là sẽ nha à
gì
chấm x này là lời là từng từng tháng Một
này tăng trên này
cái này có thể hơi mới các bạn một tí
nhưng cái này cũng gần nhiên like cốt mà
nó không nó sẽ hơi nâng cao một tí các
bạn về sau xem lại các bạn sẽ dễ hình
dung hơn
tôi có thử in lại
Thường mấy ông cứ cứ làm in lại từng cái
từng bước từng bước một đó chắc nhá đồ
là tại rít rít là trong trường hợp này
là từng thành một con luôn này
đó sẽ đi lại từng bình luận xem chọn lại
không Vẫn bạn đó im lặng được lần lượt
Ok có vẻ vẫn chuẩn với loạn sau đó trong
trường hợp này tôi sẽ lấy nội dung của
bình luận đấy thì
Xin chào
Ừ trước hết thì tôi có xem từng cái này
đã
Ừ cái này thử cái à méo này kĩ nhá cái
bình luận này nếu mà lấy chữ của cả cái
bình luận này nó sẽ bao gồm cả tên rồi
kiếm mất rồi
đúng ạ Mẹ ông Bảy ông để kỹ chữ ở trong
này nó sẽ có cái chữ Thuận này trúng Bẫy
cả hai cái gì đó thì trong trường hợp
này tôi chỉ muốn lấy đến thằng con của
nó là tôi một lần đến cái thằng con này
nó nó là từ thằng cha nhá Thằng cha đây
đúng họ đến thằng con là cái thằng nó có
cái
data-size và là như này comment body ạ
đúng đại mình sẽ lời cả cụm như thế này
đi mình sẽ gọi thằng con này rồi mới lấy
cái chữ ở trong thằng con này thì nó sẽ
hợp lý hơn vợ bố mẹ tôi thử à
Á đù get này file đến thằng con fine
nghĩa là tìm thằng con ở bên trong đó
đấy sẽ là
đít Có cái có cái data-size này tức là
mình sẽ hoặc mua cái này sẽ có cả cụm
như thế này Đấy sau đó thì ông sẽ thêm
khái niệm là chấm sách nữa để lấy nội
dung của nó
à Tôi nhớ đấy Thử Thử thì biết Thử thì
biết nữa đó ok chưa 3x này đó đó ổn chưa
đấy tôi đã in ra tất cả Ok rồi có bạn
thì
bây giờ chỉ đơn giản thôi là mấy ông
kiểm tra xem lại cái cái bình luận đấy
nó có chứa trong chuỗi của nó
ở trong chuỗi của nó khó chữa chứa dấu
sao hay không chứ sao không đúng ạ thì
các bạn sẽ tìm hàm là in string hả Ừ
chị đã được
chị Xuka thằng ri nó có cái hàm để mà
tìm tìm có sẵn in Tech thì phải tôi nhớ
có
subtech à
khi
con tên là nội dung I
à à
à
Tôi nhớ là có hàm của nó có luôn không
cần phải lấy Hà Nội dung ra thôi Đây lại
hình như cái đấy ạ
ăn Tết
ừ ừ
từ hôm nay có mặt của em không cười
không phải
tay rồi
em hỏi con trai của đơn giản đi là
Switch
Asus Trinh đi search string
contain chứa chưa có cái gì đó lại
file nó chỉ là tìm thằng con mấy trăm
thôi chứ nó không tìm trong chuỗi đâu
đấy nghĩa là chỗ ấy đấy sẽ in Plus Trỗi
gì đó đó thế là được lắm
Ừ đúng rồi hình mình nhớ như hàm con tên
thì nhớ là thế
ý là hàm xốp đỡ gì vậy thôi Chúc bỏ qua
đây á cứ làm đi cô đơn giản thôi Chưa
cần phải cao siêu dùng nhiều hà làm gì
cả trà sữa bây giờ mình có chuối rồi là
sự đây mình cứ có chỗ rồi ông ạ Mình nhà
để chỗ này
thì
mình sẽ đặt tên ở đây mình led chỗ ở đây
nha đi chưa gặp lại chỗ ấy sẽ băng là
bạn này đúng đoạn xong rồi Ít
chủ ấy này xin Plus này
biểu tượng sao chẳng ạ vợ
Hình như thằng này nó trả về chua phone
rồi Vậy mình nhớ thế
chị xem nhé á
Vì sao phải chu này chào cái phone này
Ok nếu mà xu Nếu đúng thì ra quan trọng
nếu đúng thì sao đâu ạ
ừ ừ
I really có hàm có tên đấy nhé Nếu mà
đúng thì mình sẽ phải làm như thế nào
thì sẽ phải tìm đến cái thẻ ra thể A của
cái cũng của cái bình luận đấy đúng cũng
phải của cái bình luận đấy rồi mình xóa
đó mình tìm thẻ này có cái này giả hết
thì mình sẽ tạo copy code này ra ở bên
này đi được ạ sau đó thì mình làm tiếp
anh xóa mày đi
Mở camera đôla không Này đây mình sẽ tìm
đến cái thẻ ra này
mình sẽ là ờ
ừ ừ
thì
mình sẽ là đô la just này chấm pha này
rồi tìm đến thế ah
em có cái class này à
chú chó sau đó thì mình cần bấm mở cái
thẻ đấy để nó lại nhảy ra cái này cơ Nó
không bị lăng nhăng lý nếu không thấy
đoạn này rất là lằng nhằng tuổi tý mới
ông xem thì ra chỉ có Tùng tôi chưa là
cốt đến nổi 20 30 gốc đấy thôi nhưng mà
Mấy ông thấy rất là ngoan đúng không ạ
đó đó tìm với thẻ ra để mình sẽ đặt tên
là nó là cái mình đặt tên Đây nút đi
hai nút bằng cái này
bấm vào nút là nút chấm click thế này
kiểu Nga trả lại
để để để để tôi thử đã tôi sẽ thử thằng
đầu tiên thôi thử trước xem có được
không đã thì mình sẽ
the Black parade mình sẽ lắp lắp tại cày
đây trước đi
chứ không chạy vòng lặp ở đây mình không
lại bấm được tất cả các nút cùng một lúc
được đâu mình sẽ phải bấm lần lượt từng
lũ một đây là tôi sẽ Black ngăn ngắt
vòng họp tại đây đã
à à
xin lỗi
A AB break the Face không có tác dụng ở
trong vòng lọc hối
để tôi tra lại Không Ở mình sẽ dùng
Return
[âm nhạc]
bởi vì cái này một con chuẩn Đấy là các
bạn sẽ không dùng Black để mà nhát được
mà phải dùng với tơ này để mà nó kết
thúc Kết thúc vòng lặp
ừ ừ
Nghe có vẻ không được nút này không bấm
nút này nó không tìm thấy
mình sẽ thử indaclub trước ạ
à à
ừ ừ
anh ạ
i i
thì mình sẽ lấy thằng quấy đi nút này có
rồi
những hình ảnh nude được bấm nó nó vừa
nãy mình ở kéo ở trên này nên không thấy
đúng rồi mình phải đi mày cái bình luận
ở dưới đây mày đúng
trở lại nhé ạ
Ừ thế nhưng nút được bấm ở đâu đấy rồi
tôi xem ạ ạ
anh Thái
khi sex anh đợi tôi tí
các
bạn phải lại nút rồi à
Ừ cái nút đầu tiên lại nút đầu tiên ở
đâu nhỉ
ăn Tết
cho nhau
cho mấy con đây
nè nút về à
thì tại sao nước này không được Bấm nhỉ
chú ý
[âm nhạc]
để để để để tôi thử nha à
Ừ thôi
E
với ạ
ừ ừ
Bí Ẩn
à
À đây
à à
Em Yêu Anh
em tắt nhưng mà hơi tôi tôi đang phải
hơi lạ một tí
nút tại vị trí được không này để tôi lại
gần nút tại vị trí không đã
ừ ừ
anh ạ
một chút tại viện - không có vẻ vẫn ra à
Ừ nhưng mà khi bấm vào nút này nó lại
bấm cái thằng cuối mình còn Return Ở Đây
Rồi mày nghỉ tại nó phải không
có ai Peter nữa này không tác dụng ngắt
cái phối kia rồi biết Black For
Speed thì xem em
Ê
pete ơn chua ạ
Xin
chào Vẫn Bấm cái nút cuối thế không đúng
mình mình cần mình mình cần bấm là mình
cần bấm cái nút à
Em làm gì đó ok
à à
xe máy
ở đây
Ừ every đã được
ở đây để tôi thử dùng cái hành LG ở nhà
à
anh ạ
ảnh
chụp lấy
ngay các bài Happy Nó phóng sinh Vina
không áp dụng được trong seri rồi à
a Black
chi
tiết Serie A a neighbor mới đẹp luôn à
ở trong trẻ em
ở
trong phủ cái này thế
Anh remix vợ 87 được không ạ
He
has written for à Ok Ok
tanfo nó mới nhận
hiểu rồi
Mình đang phải mò một tí thôi Thông cảm
các bạn gì á đổi này thằng ít đã ạ
em hãy về đây gần như là đẹp thế
sự thật đặt đợi làm gì lúc không
Blackberry tên phone đi
chú ý
vì nó không nhận luôn à
xe hơi lạ
chứ
không phải bấm mà được ở đây chứ
bộ phim 18 tuổi à
Em
in ra lại Biến nút tại vị trí được không
này xem có ra được nút này không này
written Phone này
vẫn ra được nút ở đây đây
xe cái cái hơi bị khó chịu ở một tí với
thằng thằng Facebook này là thỉnh thoảng
Click vào nó không có tác dụng gì không
nên là mình cứ phải chạy đi chạy lại một
cái Script rõ ràng là trông có vẻ là cốt
đúng nhưng mà đáy ông theo tôi chạy lại
lại lại ra đây hơi bị buồn cười lắm ạ
à OK thì nói cho đại khái đoạn này Thực
ra không cần để Return for đoạn này đâu
Mấy ông có nick xong rồi ông draff
[âm nhạc]
mèo Delete Xong hồi máu lại nick xuống
đáy dưới là được mà đúng không ạ bây
click để cái Delete ở như nào à à
sau khi mà bấm vào cái nút này nó lại
hiển thị ra cái như thế này thì béo lại
phải tìm đến cái á
ở đây
Xin chào đời tôi cho ông xem nhé
Ý tôi là không điểm này
bác ạ
o0o
ở đâu
à à
ở
Đô La hiện nay
khi click
phải chưa biết được thử cái này à
a magus
chị
sẽ không nhận thấy mình sẽ thử cái à
em đổi nó thành như này
mấy bạn sẽ thắc mắc mình tại sao nó
không như này còn việc khi mà gọi Để như
này tiên nó trả về nó trả về một thằng
như các bạn thấy nhưng thực ra nó trả về
mạnh đánh trúng phải trả một thằng đâu
nên anh nha mình phải gọi cụ thể
thao đầu tiên họ sẽ phải như thế này à
chú
chó của chạy được ngon rồi đấy thế thôi
Bây giờ mình sẽ xóa đoạn hit ơn phone
như này thì mới ông sẽ thấy
anh xóa
ừ ừ
ở đây nó trong Facebook ra cảnh báo là
làm làm gì đó tất cả tao không muốn tâm
tao bực sẽ xóa thôi
à à Đúng rồi hình như vậy cái bình luận
này của bản thân mình nên thành ra lạ
cái nút này nó cái cái cái cái này nó
lại là
không phải thích cái bồ nó là
cái thằng đầu tiên mẹ nó lại bấm mà bấm
với thằng ad ít mưa rồi
Em à mình hiểu cái đoạn này như thế thì
mình sẽ phải
chứa phải chứa cái mình sẽ áp dụng cái
vừa nãy ít có bạn cái đề cập là mình sẽ
là content chứ áo cái chữ Delete thì nó
chuẩn hơn bởi vì cái class này nó là hai
xanh này có cùng chung một cái class nên
là hai cùng cấp nhau nếu các bạn không
thì nó sẽ là edit chứ không phải lại
delete nữa nên là bây giờ mình sẽ con
tên
con tên là tách
A selector ở
3G giảm ạ
A2 chấm là con tên tách Đá như này chọn
đấy à
I believe I
I like
Em thử nhớ
đó thôi xóa cả hay bình luận một cái
chớp nhoáng nổi loạn thường là thực ra
tôi bảo cái trải nghiệm mà thực ra không
tốt rồi nhanh quá nha Không Facebook nó
đang cảnh báo tôi luôn mấy ông thấy đúng
loại thì bị bây giờ chúng ta sẽ tạo một
cái độ trễ gì đó mình sẽ tạo một cái độ
trễ
trong mỗi vòng lặp với vòng lặp này các
bạn hãy chạy rất nhanh thành ra là thành
là cốt của mình lỡ nếu thấy cốc nhà nó ạ
Chưa đến 10 dòng Đâu đúng ạ Tại mới dám
đâu 9 đọc ạ thì
nhưng mà Mấy ông kiểu chạy như thế bài
đăng này đưa đã có 700 bình luận mấy ông
ngồi Spam là sự Xóa tầm 100 đến bình
luận gái là mấy ông
bị khóa nick ngay Nếu mà spam khó Xóa
nhanh quá Chưa đến 5 giây mộ xóa 100
bình luận nó nó sẽ nghi ngờ và loại khóa
khóa cũng mơ của ông ông Hôm
nay là mấy ông không nên chạy vòng lặp
để mà làm cái gì đó như thế rất là nhanh
ngôn ngữ lập trình được sử lý nhanh lắm
nên liên lạc nếu không phải tạo độ trễ
độ trễ trong ra Swift nó sẽ là xe Tam
Mao là sẽ tạo độ trễ gì đó
ảnh đẹp anh
sex Cà Mau
which I
ừ ừ
anh
bỏ đi lại câu hỏi tao cái gì đam mê cho
con à
ê ê
các
bạn đợi mình tìm mình mình thử xem vụ
tọa độ trễ à
ừ ừ
cho cô bé
ê ê
anh xem đi
à à
ờ ờ
anh không Hồi trước ở tôi chạy tung
nhưng mà tôi không trào ra Speed tôi
chạy wp thì nó có cái độ chạy ngon hơn
em phải xử lý này một cái hàm này sẽ gọi
anh xếp theo nào này
à à
nghe lời vợ à
à Vì sao cho nó cũng nhiều xe mà không
cần nghe tiếng Anh
em nhìn bạn này Béo ngấy cốt trong phức
tạp fake a
à à
em nghĩ cái ổ này đánh giá cao phết I
để tạo một hạt mà tạo độ trễ sau đó gọi
là hầm đấy cứ vài giây gọi hàng đấy
à à
Ừ được để tối thử Phát
anh
và tôi sẽ lại
bình luận test một loại
có vai Dù sao thì gì đó mô
tả một bình luận test 2
chị sẽ chỉ có một số sao chị ạ Tôi sẽ
chạy
mà tôi Tôi mong tôi muốn là kiểu tầm 1
giây nó sẽ xóa một bình luận ít nhất là
như thế cho nó giống người bình thường
luôn vậy không phải giống máy mình sẽ
Ừ
nếu mà chạy lại cái này lập tức là nó sẽ
xóa luôn đúng ạ Giờ mình sẽ
à à
cho con cái hàm thế này sau đó thì mình
sẽ gọi đến cái hàm đấy Kiểu như thế này
bạn bị sẽ khái niệm vô xét đó năm trước
à
ạ sau đó đi Ở đây sẽ là phải Sau đó gì ờ
ờ
Âm Nhạc
Ừ
thôi con dê hóa không biết được
ok 2star phải lấy tiếp này
Ê
cảm ơn
ấn
vào đây các bạn là các bạn sẽ thấy là
cái này sẽ là
đa
số thời gian mà cái này sẽ là một 1.000
đấy sẽ bằng một giây ạ
Tôi sẽ đem một nghìn đấy
đó chạy thử cô sẽ là mình đây từng tháng
từng năm trong cũng về chạy được rồi thử
nhận
được một giây rồi xóa đấy
à Không có gì xảy ra đâu đó người ta
không có gì xảy ra cơ à
Ừ để tôi xem lại xem có gì đó xảy ra đây
không
anh em men.net à
à à
xe chạy Đua này chạy được đấy
Em có phải là nó đang đợi delay một tí
nhưng số sáng có vẻ vẫn chạy được đoạn
đều tiếp theo tiếp theo là bây giờ mình
sẽ ấn loát bình luận lát bình luận thì
lại lót từng bình luận này ra này
Ừ thì mình chỉ nó giả là mình sẽ
cho mình mình sẽ là xóa hết
em xóa hết tất cả xóa hết tất cả xong
rồi ạ sau đó mình lót thêm giờ mình lại
xóa
thì các bạn hiểu đối với các bạn nghĩa
là
lát này
xóa này Sao lại lót này lại xóa đâu bạn
thì bài toán ở đây là nó phải vòng lại
loạn vòng lặp
ở vòng lập này chưa Lát rồi Xóa luận
à à
ý
thì cái việc
sau đó thì lại loạt ở xóa cho đến khi
nào mà không không lót lần nữa thì thôi
Được ạ cùng nhưng
không chạy nữa ngọn đầu tiên là mình sẽ
lấy ra được cái bình luận này ah lấy lấy
ra được cái nút này
gì lạ không
da1 như thế này để để tôi thử xem nhé
tôi chú đắp liên kết cái Tab này đã cho
chắc tôi đang nhi class này có thể thay
đổi lại nhìn class này trong mông lung
quá à
Ừ đẹp đấy
Hà Tĩnh
ừ ừ
ở đại một cái bấm được vào nữa này à
chú ý
anh vẫn một cái OK anh nghe có lát này
là đúng thôi nghĩa là mình cứ bấm bấm
bấm thêm nhiều sẽ càng thêm nhiều lắm
cái đôla không mà là đối với Gomez nó sẽ
hiểu là gọi đến cái thằng aligment mà
ông vừa xây lách bằng cái này để tôi
mình sẽ có thể dùng cái xe lách này
trước với ISO thử dùng đôla không Nó sẽ
hiển thị ra class kèm theo tên thẻ kèm
theo ID của thế hệ đời mà ông sẽ gọi lên
chính xác cái thẻ mà ông vừa chọn ạ
ý cái mẹo đấy mẹ anh Tuấn chị thôi khách
nên mình làm chạy vòng lặp đúng ạ Mình
sẽ càng lặp là
Ờ Ờ
mình mình không biết được cụ thể là có
bao nhiêu vòng lặp phải cần chạy Mình
chỉ cần chạy khi nào mà hết hết cái nút
có thể bấm thì bây giờ Black loạn mình
sẽ vòng lặp while
cho tôi biết ngoài lại được à ngoai này
khi họ mấy ông mấy ông
ngoài mặc định cứ phải chu đi thế luôn
đúng đi ngoạn và kiểu Nếu mà khi mà vòng
khi mà cái nút nó không hiểu mình sẽ
hiểu là nếu nút còn còn thì thì tiếp tục
Còn nếu mà lúc không còn là ngược lại
đúng ạ thì mình sẽ Black trả nợ thế
đúng ạ kết thúc
thì cái vụ cái nút này mình sẽ luôn lấy
cái nút này là bọn mình được tiller nút
trước đã
Tại sao rồi mình sẽ nút bằng
Đôla cái vua cái class mình vừa tìm được
à à
ý là cái class a a
Ừ tôi chọn lại cái đấy đi xem class nhé
Nó không Này class này
Nhưng mà như tôi đã nói cái này nó lấy
ra bản chất nó vẫn lấy ra là dạng mang
mình cần lấy theo đầu tiên thì mình sẽ
là tại vị trí được không này mình sẽ lấy
ra
à à
Ừ cái kiểu như thế này
anh không ông không quay nút kiểu như
thế quay nút Thật ra vẫn được thờ da
quanh mắt tại bị gì không mà nó chuẩn
hơn này à
cô bạn kia nói hay cũng được chị sẽ quay
nút kiểu nhà cũng hợp lý này à
à à
bóng đá
à
mà nút tại vị trí đứng không click
thì nó sẽ chạy những cái quan trọng là ở
đây nó có bài toán là khi mặc từ nick
xong cái nút đấy
Sau đó thì mình xóa này sau đó em mình
lại quay lại click lại nút phát nữa đúng
không ạ
ở
Nghệ An toàn bộ quá trình này nó phải
đợi nhau đợi nhau không thể không thấy
nút thì cứ bấm cho cơ thể xóa được chứ
ra làm về cũng được nhưng mà nhưng mà
ở cây cái việc nó hơi bị
nó hơi bị kiểu dạng là nó nhanh quá tôi
vẫn cảm thấy mến mạc cái nút này vừa cứ
bấm bấm liên tục Nghĩa Ông cứ Hình dung
có hai thằng cùng ngồi chung một mái một
ông thì cứ liên tục bấm người nhút nhát
21 Ông ở dưới bấm xoáy ngang quán
Facebook độ nghi ngờ nên tôi đang nghĩ à
sẽ cho cả cái việc bấm của lót nút và
bấm xóa xoáy nên nên kiểu phải đợi nhau
mà ra suýt không có cơ chế đợi lòng em
nó bất đồng bộ là như kiểu thằng làm
được gọi trước thì thằng ấy cứ chạy thôi
nó không có được nhau gì cả Bây giờ tôi
muốn cho mấy thằng ấy đợi nhau cái thì
mình sẽ phải
à đây tôi còn có cái nút rồi chúng sẽ là
nét des nút tải thêm bình luận để ý
à à
Ừ
nó đúng không Thế mày lấy
1000 cho vòng lặp này nó lại không một
vòng lặp này là vòng lặp
của riêng tất cả bình luận và không liên
quan gì cả
Ừ
nếu đây vòng lọc của tất cả bình luận nó
nên độc lập à
số tiền lót nút này
hai nút vào giờ được lót thì
à à
ừ ừ
khi khai báo Hà mà đúng không nuốt Tải
thế bình luận đấy
xe tải thêm bình luận nút này được bấm
này
cái này nó sẽ có trường hợp là nút này
không còn tồn tại thì bấm nữa
hai cây = lập của anh nhé
Chu này
nhà tôi cứ làm kiểu ythu nha bây giờ
chắc đi
mình sẽ là ít
hai
nút tải thêm bình luận đây
thì
mình sẽ Flex cáp quang lập
theo là mình sẽ click thêm này à
Ừ mình vứt cái này xuống cuối được cái
này thì ra bớt xuống cuối chạy sau khi
mà xóa xong trước lúc đầu khi vào tra
thì ông có xóa trước đã Sau đó ông ấy
tải thêm sau đó thì ông quay lại à
Xóa tiếp sau đó loại Tải thêm cứ thế Tại
tôi thấy như thế này khá hợp lý này
tại Cốt đã đến mức gần 35 một loạn Đúng
rồi mới hợp web xong Nhìn cái đoạn này
thì tôi Công nhận với mấy ông nó trông
choáng tí nhưng mày ông đòi hỏi là làm
lại Cốt và nó ạ cô thực tế nó sẽ như thế
này mấy ông có thể thấy cái khó tuổi
công nhận
như tôi đã nói Làm lập trình viên thì
chúng ta không nghĩ rằng là côn mình một
phát chạy được ngay mà tôi sẽ tạm bỏ cái
vòng đó có ai trước đã đúng ạ Tôi sẽ tạm
bỏ vòng lặp while trước
tránh việc là kiểu cốt một phát làm gì
chuyện cũng được Phát ăn ngay không ạ ạ
Ừ để tôi cứ chạy tại Thêm bình luận được
các thứ trong mẹ tôi ổn đã
Ừ
để cho chắc cú hơn để tôi có tải lại hẳn
chàng sẽ chắc ý
chị đã có thêm hai bình luận có sao rồi
nè Ok đỡ phải mất công test nữa
à à
3G zin
ai đấy thế tôi phải confirm Hãy viết lại
sản phẩm Chu Giá em
bỏ đấy đỡ mất công cơm
rồi tôi copy đoạn này à
xin lỗi
xin lỗi là chỗ black
black này
không còn Black nữa
anh
không còn back này
mình bỏ cái vòng lặp voi mà còn đâu
Black nữa đâu ạ
a
nice Chứng tỏ là cái này nó không để ở
đây à à à
ừ ừ
anh béo hay vừa
Em không
biết cái này hình như là tôi đang thấy
nó hơi bị delay quá Ừ Thế xem lại đi
ở
Tam Mao Tam Mao
Ừ
nếu thấy không nhận nó đi lấy hơi lâu
thôi Chả biết nó có xoáy không được đi
lên
1.000 mà là một giây mà ở đây là nó có
xóa này
delay hơi lâu nhỉ Thôi cũng được sạc
miễn là cốt chạy mình cảm thấy sướng có
được
nút này để nuôi xem nhé á
Ừ
hình như nó đỡ được nuốt được bấm rồi
đấy Nếu thấy à bình luận vừa nãy là 3x
bây giờ nó bình luận lên trên cùng nó
thành như này rồi đúng không ạ đó lũ
được bấm rồi Trông có vẻ ngon rồi có vẻ
ngon rồi để tôi sẽ cắn chung test lại
đây mình chạy bằng lập ngon không ạ Bây
giờ tôi sẽ lại té lại nha Đây là bình
luận test à
ở nước ta
à à
Ừ tôi muốn có gì không biết
Em thử nhé Phát ăn luôn rồi à
à à
Ừ
thì sẽ phải xóa bình luận mày đi này sau
đó thì lót thêm này
gọi ôi
em
kéo lên hình như nó nó thay đổi làm cho
cái đoạn này tôi lỗi hết rồi
chạy vào lập nhiều quá nha nó lỗi luôn
cả trên này của tôi rồi
nếu mà ông thấy không cho diện này thì
cũng chẳng biết chẳng biết sao nữa nó gì
Còn tôi thì vấn đề rồi à
nhà
nghỉ bình luận này nhưng chưa bay nè
bây giờ đấy khi nghe tôi đây thì nghe
máy tôi đâu rồi chạm vào là quite mà
đoạn này hơi không ạ tôi thế đoạn này
hơi nguy đấy nếu mà không Không tìm thấy
Black Tôi nghĩ vòng làm ngoài thì nó mày
tôi chết rồi
Ừ cái đáy ấy cho tôi bảo là máy hạn chế
du học không quay tôi đã dặn mấy hôm rồi
à
anh nói chút là đại khái như thế Ờ vậy
tôi treo rồi và tôi nghĩ là thôi Thực ra
ở trên tội cũng ít thôi hình ngựa tôi
chỉ còn 12 cái bình luận sao tôi chưa
xóa thôi Ờ
Tự
nhiên Đại khá như thế để tôi vừa rồi tôi
nói qua cho mấy ông hình dung việc là
dụng ra Suite để mà làm cốt tool chạy
như thế là tương đối ổn rồi đúng không ạ
30 tối nghĩa là thằng ra sự thằng
Facebook có khi chặn luôn tôi tí tôi có
bị bằng bằng đăng xuất ra ngoài mà ạ
Ừ
Ok Nhưng mày ông hiểu đó là cách
một lập trình viên khi mà gặp một bài
toán rồi sẽ giải quyết vấn đề như thế
nào giải quyết như thế nào ngọn có thể
tra Google có thứ là sử lý nha tương đối
cũng tương đối mà nó không ạ
Ừ ok đại khái như thế nhá máy tôi treo
chắc mình cũng tạm dừng đây thôi ok à
Ừ có gì tôi sẽ trả lời mấy thắc mắc nãy
giờ méo Hỏi buổi sau nhé
Chào mấy ông nha à
ừ ừ